being proclaimed by me provost of six
dollars on this the 20th day of april
2012 that sixth college will be covered
in environment college for a day
let's hear it for conan o'brien
utility
[Applause]
i can't hear you
[Applause]
i have one question for all of you
what the hell do you mean
naming the college after me for one day
it should be the permanent name of six
college should it not
what day what the hell is that
it should be in all perpetuity conan
o'brien college cause i change things
[Applause]
alcohol would be free
marijuana would not just be legal it
would be mandatory
you would have to prove that you had so
much a day
[Applause]
i love you too sir
finally a woman thank you
[Applause]
i'm still interested
that wasn't a no to you that's a yes to
both of you
what do you mean now you're saying no
no no no no no we're going to get to
both of you all right
ladies and gentlemen
i was under the impression
that this was going to be a permanent
change to the name of this college
i thought they'd be bronze plaques
i heard rumors of a stone statue
and i get here and every thing that says
conan o'brien college is written on a
dry erase board
it's going to come right off
and tomorrow it's the zac efron library
oh you like that do you
well i've met him
guys got incredible b.o
this is all off the record
now it is an incredible honor an
incredible honor to be
have six college named after me for just
this one and i don't want to just
say hello to everyone from sixth college
i know we have some other people here
earl warren is there a warrant here
[Applause]
[Music]
john mayer
[Applause]
how did john mayer get a college named
after him
i get it for a day and john mayer
and around to the husband
and that's it
[Applause]
is it john weir
[Music]
more
more
[Music]
i hear you guys are stoners that's the
word on you guys
that's the word
that's the word you can't say that about
eleanor roosevelt
raphael here
[Applause]
[Music]
it's an honor to meet all of you
i know that i am quite sickly looking in
person
why is that funny
that's a joke
i was told hey man you're going to san
diego
it's going to be incredible
it's like northern ireland here
was that me did it change the second i
got here
it's 44 degrees outside
there's a fog settling in
i had the pleasure of meeting a lot of
you today
[Music]
[Applause]
some of you hugged me for a long time
you know who you are
there are some ladies and two guys that
wouldn't let go
but i'm here to tell you that i will do
what it takes for this school
i will do what it takes
i will do anything it takes
to be a good founding member
of conan o'brien college
i will fight your strongest man
have him stand up where's your strongest
man i will bite him
wait
oh my god
[Applause]
up
[Applause]
i've never had to fight a guy who's
wearing a t-shirt that says sixth loves
coco
all the fear is leaving my body
when you stood up i'm like that's a
tough guy
that guy looks like he works out oh he
loves cool
[Music]
we'll fight later all right
all right he's still standing he wants
to do this
you really want to do this don't you
all right now i'm here for a reason
ladies and gentlemen i didn't come here
to fight you
i came to love you
[Applause]
i came to share some of my expertise
i've been through a little bit in my
life i've been through some experiences
and i one of my favorite things is
talking to young people
and the people i've met here today
you are
interested you're curious
you're fascinating and i'm told that you
have questions and what i really want to
do is have a dialogue tonight i want you
guys to ask me you can ask me anything
you want
if you wish to touch me you may
you can rub any part of my body it's
pretty much i can't feel anything at
this point
you get to a certain age where it just
goes
but i'm here to answer your questions
and i don't know what the format is is
there going to be a moderator little's
been explained to me
what's that
oh the moderator's coming what are you
doing
what kind of school is this
anyway i thought i'd take your questions
and we'll talk about it we'll talk about
media we'll talk about media in the 21st
century
uh we'll talk about um my life
the women i've been with
the stars i've seen naked uh
and i'll pretty much tell you the honest
to god's truth i'll tell you everything
i know
so you just
ask away and i believe
ms losh now is going to answer she's
going to ask the questions is that right
you're not going to oh the students ask
the questions so there are two
microphones in the hall and we also have
a box go questions for conan
um that that should magically appear at
this point a box of questions yes i
don't understand
ah
okay okay these are questions for me yes
all right
did you just find these or these are
asked by the student body
these aren't like where it's like
craigslist where can i get a toyota
looking for a futon
willing to spend up to sixty
this is a sad dollars you want to start
with a sad one
yes
all right with all of your experience
and education what is the best way to
approach a hard economy for a job
i came here to have fun
the hell is this
i wish i had the magic answer
i do not
uh
i'll give anybody a job who wants one
you name the salary
for what
oh okay uh look pal
uh yes that is a that is a tough
question i didn't think i'd be getting
questions like that but i'll do my best
to answer it
uh i've been incredibly fortunate in my
life
i did not get into my line of work to
make money i didn't care actually how
much money i made i got into my line of
work because i was really passionate
about it and uh that actually ended up
turning into a job
and although i can't tell my bosses this
i do it for nothing i really love doing
my job
and uh and so i believe that you start
by doing doing anything you can to find
something that you enjoy doing
and i know that that sounds like an easy
thing to say but long before i ever got
a writing job in television or a
performing job in television i did
whatever it took i would get coffee
for uh
as a runner on the first comic relief
which was a special my job was to get
coffee for estelle getty from the golden
girls
[Applause]
yeah so imagine this guy running around
getting coffee for estelle getty that is
what i did and i didn't care i was near
show business i knew that somehow if i
worked hard and i kept my eyes and ears
open so go to where they're doing what
you're passionate about and if you have
to reheat pound cake if you have to
specifically reheat pound cake
make coffee
uh don't have an attitude do whatever it
takes uh but uh get the job done and if
you work hard and you show that you have
ability you end up moving up the ladder
it just happens
now let's hope that the next question is
more joyous
okay
please line up at the two microphones in
the center uh we have another question
this is from david todd who is a third
year poli sci major from camarillo
california way too much information
it's already out of my head i don't know
what he does
is it a man is it a woman
who is it
it's david oh
well sadly when you have these
proportions there is no body double
find another six foot five inch guy with
my hair
whose legs begin up here
i have the weirdest
proportioned body in the world and i
hate to disappoint you ladies
but we're right to strip nude and i will
if you stick around for the whole show
why no it's not pretty
it's a shade of white you've never seen
it's a shade of white that doesn't exist
in san diego
it's a bluish white a park belly white
my
belly button is like around here i'm
touching my belly button right now
when i hitch up my pants to their proper
adjusted height and walk around it's a
freak show
so there's no finding a body double
there nasa is building a robot but uh
it's exploded four times it's a mess so
no i do not have a body double i'd love
a body double but i pity the person who
would actually get the job
next question and don't be shy how about
one of the ones from the microphone
hi conan i'm cheryl hi cheryl how are
you i'm good i really love your hairs i
had a question about it yes um so it's
really a big part of your celebrity
status your hair so is there some
special maintenance that goes into
keeping it perfect and orange
it's a very personal question
but i'm going to answer it
this
hair
has been with me since i was a child
and when i was like in the fifth grade i
started combing it up into this wave and
i don't know why
this hair has not been in style since
i've been alive
i know a lot of you are young and you
think okay maybe that was the style
in like the lakes this was never the
style
i don't know why i did this
but i combed it up this way
and uh then over the years i've
perfected various ways to maintain its
integrity
uh there's a bathroom spackling compound
in here
mayonnaise
i bake this in a kiln every afternoon
for two hours
i crush very specific red berries that
are found in south africa
to create this color
this is the product of about 65 people
working very hard to create a belgian
french pastry on top of a grown man's
head
i'm glad you find it attractive
would you like to touch it step forward
get in there
[Applause]
soft and really orange
did your soul leave your body when you
touched it
see ya did you see your light when you
touched it very much did you see the
future you know
everyone else sees the future
we have another question
i'm looking at you
you can't just do that to a guy's hair
and then walk away
why
yes next question all right
this is an alumni question oh alumni
boring
don't say that
this conan character all right which one
is he
uh what is your favorite character slash
sketch from any of your shows
uh well there have been different ones
uh from the simpsons i think the
monorail episode that i work on
from my different shows it's really hard
to say i did a baseball remote once uh
where i played uh 19th century baseball
with a mustache on but that i mean
there's been too many of those little
weird things that i've liked doing over
the years
uh years and years ago on saturday live
i did a sketch called molecular the
molecular man that was really weird and
stupid and fun and my favorite things
are the ones that
borderline don't make sense and are just
really weird and left brain those are my
favorite things so uh hard to say
hard to say there's been a lot of
weirdness over the years and i can't
remember any of it
let's take another question from one of
the dark shades in the center yeah it's
really creepy we can't see who you are
so
i don't know if you're male female oh
you look like a guy a little bit of both
it's cool uh my name is uh
my name is david i'm sure david i'm an
alum from warren
what's that
my name is david i'm an alumni from
warren
i can't
he's an alumni from warren from here
because of the acoustics i heard ala
mama cali
wrong
and i was like this is an incredibly
multicultural school
welcome to our country guild we've got
skill i bow to you
i hope our customs are not strange
you're an alumni from warren and what do
you do now sir i work at the scripps
institution of oceanography ah very good
i hope this uh question touches on our
shared expertise in marine life
and the answer is bayleen i believe
that was what you were going to ask
right
so
in the past couple decades you've
interviewed matt talked with several
different people on different levels
completely uh who are the most
attractive
people you've interviewed men like
physically attractive
just say physically it's more
interesting and that's what everyone if
you say like no whose soul everyone's
gonna tune out
if you say who is just so freaking hot
everyone's on the edge of their seat how
about how about only physically and only
for a three hour period and you can't
say
david only for a three-hour period
were they disfigured after the interview
oh i mean was there an accident of some
kind what
not if certain
no no accident what does the three hours
mean
is the three hours the amount of time i
get to be okay okay you've gotten dirty
i can't do three hours 20 minutes what
we'll do 20 minutes okay
this is this is incredible uh
you're welcome oh yeah thank you
this is better than the save the economy
question for sure
what do we do
i don't know but i'll tell you who's got
a killer ass
wow that's a good question uh
well uh wow i have to say uh and it
a year a bunch of years ago when i first
saw
angelina jolie
in person don't boo
who booze angelina jolie
okay whatever all right she got your man
i'm sorry
[Applause]
i'll scratch that bitch's eyes out
in person she's like from another planet
she's like an alien she's so
beautiful that the air around her turns
to this sort of granulated molecule
that makes no sense but it's true
that's a very attractive one yeah
and uh andy richter might be the best
looking man i've ever heard
he's just got those nordic features
that's the best i can do if those two
had a baby that's some baby that's all
i'm saying
it's pretty good yeah thanks golden
thank you no problem all right this is a
question from candace yang who is a
junior
in chemical engineering slash cogside no
it's from two people alex and candace
she started as one but she made herself
too
using the molecular energizer
all right
and they want to know what's the
craziest thing you did in college
[Applause]
wow
yeah i uh yeah i thought it'd be a
really funny prank to steal
all the newspapers from the school you
know there's a rivalry i ran the college
humor magazine the lampoon and we were
wise asses and then there was the
serious newspaper that got the news out
and they're all going to go and have
important careers and we were all
alcoholics and so
not me i was you know had other problems
but uh
uh but anyway uh i thought it'd be
really funny if when they came out with
their big important issue we went and we
stole it
so uh we actually got a bunch of us got
dressed up as commandos broke into the
harvard crimson late at night all that
it was not not late at night about four
in the morning and the papers had just
been delivered but no one was there yet
we knew the exact time
when the papers would be delivered to
the office from the printing uh machines
but were not yet to be picked up and
delivered everybody and we stole them
and i thought oh that's funny now
they'll do a funny prank to us
but they didn't do a funny prank to us
they called the police
they didn't call
the harvard police the campus police who
are the nice police who say you should
give back the newspaper that'd be a good
idea you're gonna do it that's a good
idea they didn't call this place they
called the cambridge police
the cambridge police or the police that
beat your head in if they want to so i'm
thinking i'm really funny college guy
and i'm laughing in our little lampoon
building and the doorbell rings and i
open the door and there's two policemen
there and they have guns
not drawn
mine was drawn uh
i carried a gun
but anyway they uh
they i they were like did you take
newspapers and i think well i think
i may not have that's the whimsical
world of comics human
maybe i didn't maybe i didn't as thoreau
once said
you have the right to remain silent
they started reading me my rights and
they put handcuffs on me
i have never squealed faster in my life
i not only told them where the
newspapers were
but i told them everything that i had
done
it was indecent since i was a child
so yeah that was probably the weirdest
stupidest thing i did when i was in
college
yay
was it worth it no
was it worth it
no it wasn't worth it it was horrifying
i messed myself
yes next question
sorry i just got a text and i feel like
it's about a question
what's up
[Music]
wait someone texted you as they saw you
approach the microphone yeah
this is a casual place man
like the whole vibe here i don't know if
i want to ask this she's about to talk
in front of 5 000 people think i'll text
her
okay um
my original question was i wanted to
know about your most embarrassing date
story
all right
wow there's a lot of those
it's really hard to pick one uh that's a
really good one i think i did not go to
my high school prom
i uh i bailed on the prom because uh
this it's a long story but i bailed on
the prom and then immediately regretted
it and wanted to ask this girl but my i
was friends with some other people that
said the prom who goes to the prom don't
need to go to the prom
because no one asked them and no one
would go with them
so i hung out with you know it was a bad
group that i hung out with they're like
we don't need the problem who needs the
prom and i was like yeah i don't need
the prom and then this girl that i like
said do you think you might go to the
prom and i was like no who needs the
prom and then it was clear that she
would have gone to the prom with me okay
so i don't go to the prom and it gets
worse
that's my mayor quimby uh
i so my dad i don't go to the prom that
night and he said that i had to plant
these uh bushes
for him and he was like and i hadn't
done it he was like you gotta get on
that man i'm like all right i'll do it
somebody'll let my own shoe and then
i'll show you
i was like what was that i'd be like
nothing
so i went in the backyard and and uh we
didn't have enough fertilizer so i got
my dad's crappy 1970 pontiac i drove
to the gardening supply store i loaded a
bunch of fertilizer in the back and the
fertilizer dust was all over me i'm
driving back i get to an intersection a
prom limo pulls up next to me and the
window lowers and it's jimmy hennessy
and the girl who was gonna who wanted to
go to the prom with me and i'm covered
in horse manure dust
and i gave one of those like weak smiles
and they had they were it was like the
coolest prom limo you've ever seen
you know snoop dogg was in there and
there was a disco ball and
fireworks were going off and they were
splitting the atom and drinking and
then the window went back up and they
took off and i went home and finished
planting some poinsettias that have
since died
there's your story for you
now i'm depressed
between the economy and that question
i don't think i can take too much here
i love you too sir
again always the dudes it's too late
i'm with him and him all right
this is a question from caitlin
from rosie
i don't know how to pronounce this
caroline
you can tell she's a pharmacological
student and she wants to know if the
world was taken over by zombies what
would be your strategy to survive
[Applause]
finally
a question that makes sense to me
that's why i'm here thank you caitlyn
what about the academy
what do you think is the best strategy
for the future
that's not why i'm here
killing zombies is why i'm here
[Applause]
well
i'll get to that
i think the best thing to do would be to
go to a place that has a big supply of
food
that's in a fairly remote location i'd
head to the
denver airport
it's a lot of food there feeds a lot of
people it's fairly remote and i'd make
sure they had a few friends with me we
had a lot of shotguns
so i'd rob a sporting goods store on the
way
and i'd hold up an airport plus they
have those carts zombies move pretty
slowly you can get in one and drive away
if you get in trouble plus zombies will
be confused by that conveyor belt
they'll get on it and it's going the
wrong way
they'll spend hours and hours thinking
they're coming after you when they're
not
meanwhile
yeah
there you go
meanwhile i had the cinnabon stuffing my
face
so that's the plan are we all in on it
when the zombies cut we all need a
denver airport
just do it
all right we should ask another question
from the dark people out there yes hello
hello conan
um hi i'm i'm one of those girls who was
hugging you earlier yes
i remember you again um i was wondering
if you could do the invisible
is that an invocation
oh
i'm sorry that's so inappropriate
don't act like this when you get into
the real world
i'm way too old to be talking to women
but i do it and it's never worked for me
uh
what would
[Music]
so my question was it's actually not a
question it's a request yes um can you
do the invisible hip stream it's called
the string games
[Applause]
you got to cut the string that's
important
security
security find out her name yes
john is a digital art major he says his
year is one year which i don't know what
it even means
i am one year
that sounds so profound
and he writes if you couldn't perform
what would be your second career
uh wow
i guess writing just writing i i do be a
college professor you don't think that's
an awesome career i think that is
performing in a way you're in front of
it
and i mean that as a compliment the
professors are in front of people
they're in the zone they gotta think on
their feet so i uh i don't know i think
i would
write but i do love to be out in front
of people so some sort of dancer i
suppose
sort of exotic dancer
that's so low hello
look here you like dance for us
dance about clown
bring conan o'brien you're the most
entitled people bring conan o'brien to
us
and then he will dance
[Applause]
i'll do it later
[Music]
how about this gentleman here hey
hi how are you i'm fine thanks can you
hear me
yes i can fabulous
uh so i have i have a two-part question
the first is kind of a serious one the
second also a request
uh the first is so you're giving
yourselves two questions yeah it's it
well it's the same question questions
the two that's okay that's fine i'm cool
please um so
yeah why are you hunched over like
because the microphone is short stand up
like a man
there you go
thank you you're gonna know this
look already your personality's changed
a minute ago you're like hey
well it's three but will you take it
only now you're standing up and you're
like hey o'brien shut up
i like it let's hear it all right so
what what in your opinion are are maybe
the best or most promising ways that you
see media playing a positive role on
college campuses
no no that's a good question hey come on
they can't all be about
well they should be about people's
bodies but
um
i think that
there's a lot of people
your age
and who look at
people in the media
and
they
think of them as something else you know
that person's up here that person is in
this more rarefied air and i think that
was something that i labored under for a
long time as i always looked at people
who were in the media before i managed
to break through
and i always thought that they had a
special place and they had something
real to say and maybe i didn't
and then i learned over time
that the best thing you can do when you
actually get into a place where you are
talking to more than just a handful of
people and you're on television is to
tell the truth and tell people
uh exactly what you went through
and let them know that you've
encountered difficulties that you're
uh
insecure about things that you had your
problems that you continue to have your
problems that you continue to be
insecure i have many people your age
that look at me and they tend to think
okay you've been doing this for almost
20 years and you you sort of made it
your you hit the lottery and you're done
and they don't understand that every day
that i go out and do a show is a
struggle and when something doesn't work
i feel the same pain i did when i was
15 or 14 or 13.
and my point is i really do think the
best way that adults in media can
can provide a service to younger people
to be honest with them and say
yeah i'm here here's the 15 ways i
screwed up here's the 35 things i did
right here's the 17 things i wouldn't do
again if i had the choice here's what
i've learned i'm still figuring it out
i'll never get it perfect
and i i tell almost every young person
who works for me when they go to leave
because i've mistreated them uh
when they when they go to move on when
their internships up or whatever they
come to say goodbye to me i tell them i
hope you had a good time i hope you
learned something by watching at
rehearsal how much we struggle and how
difficult it is and how sometimes i
really get down because i don't think we
have it that day and and it's not coming
together uh i hope that you learned
something and i hope that someday
uh when you're on top
you'll think of me and like give me a
bit part or something hire me and and
have a bit of a humble attitude about it
and i think that's the way that most
i think there's a uh celebrity culture
that we have now where a lot of people
get there and they kind of act like they
are the chosen ones and i think that
does a real disservice to people i think
i think reality shows the one uh
uh
and there's people that really have a
lot of people who have no craft they put
no effort into it they've some of those
people are really talented and then some
of those shows as you know are just
people uh with addiction problems and
behavior problems misbehaving in front
of the camera and then they get paid a
lot of money and i think
frankly that that's fantastic uh
i encourage you all to but i i uh
really try and get into the jersey shore
but uh
but i i that that's that's the main
that's my main answer is is to be
truthful to young people about how
difficult it is and how for me
not that much has changed since i was in
college or high school i have good days
i have bad days
i have insecurities all that stuff my
skin's a little better but other than
that nothing's changed you're looking
great but uh thank you so part of the
looking great then is that your hair has
the wave always from one side have you
ever gone the other way tried it once
yeah yeah with bleeding out my ears
all right well maybe it's just like just
shooting out of my ears like a nozzle if
you could endure it one day in the
future if you could dedicate it to us
we'd appreciate it
dedicate the the wave from the other
side and say look i i maybe look very
different it's just the wave but i
dedicate it to uh oh you want me to part
my hair on the other side one night and
dedicate it to you guys
wow
i remember that speech i gave you guys
an entitlement a while ago
can you touch your face
some night for a no you know what i'll
think about and i'll give it serious
thought if i'm going to do it for
anybody it's going to be for you
all right we have a question from andrea
m
who is a second year student in computer
science and psychology okay computer
science psychology she's from long beach
from a fellow ginger
nice
we're going extinct you know we're going
we're rapidly going extinct gingers well
she wants to know do you face
discrimination as a redhead
i'd like to say it's because i'm
red-headed
but i think it's the general way i've
conducted myself in life
it's caused me problems
i'd love to blame it i'll fill the hair
that's why people don't take me
seriously
no i've never been discriminated against
because i was i hated it when i was a
kid i had my hair was really bright
bright bright orange and i had freckles
and
i just absolutely hated my face just
hated myself
and i felt really bad girls
and all i wanted was someone to
understand me
now you guys know what i'm doing here
now
and you admire it frankly
uh but yeah i was very i i learned to
live with it
so another question yes the microphone
yeah hi um
dude
i love you guys i really do i'm not
saying that
my heart beats nine times for every one
of yours it's great
i was kind of wondering about the uh
what's like the story of your hair why
did you decide to wear it like that or
who came up i'm telling you it's the
same it's it i just i answered that one
i just did it
i know you no i know you were in another
zone uh
preparing
very nicely have you ever met conan
o'brien uh
i um yeah it's just the way i've always
done it i don't know why
since i was yes since i was shockingly
little i don't know what the problem is
with me i swear to god i just did it
it's always been that way
uh and uh i don't know what the problem
is but over the time there's so many
people in media that i can't go anywhere
without i mean on some level i guess it
worked because wherever i go people are
like you're the ass with the hair you
know
and i'm like i did it
they know me
so we have a question from susie dang
who's a third year
in biochem i don't understand what's
happening you're cheering but she's over
here
so why are you guys cheering
oh you love susie day
but she won't sit with her
[Applause]
i don't want to hear your excuses
you should be with your friends but no
you had to have the good seat
that's how it works people that's how it
works
she wants to know your biggest fear my
biggest fear
uh wow
i don't know
joking
uh i would say
[Music]
the craziest thing i don't physically uh
it's weird i don't physically fear
things so i mean i i
my wife has noticed this i really i'm
kind of like
that bulldozer's out of control i better
go stand in front of it i have like
almost a stupid golden retriever kind of
i don't i'm missing that part i'm
absolutely terrified of not making
uh an audience happy i mean that's and
and i think that's one of the things is
that when you go towards you
subconsciously go towards what you fear
most but what's i'm not a great athlete
so if i get into a touch football game
and i throw a bad pass and people laugh
at me it doesn't hurt me
because i'm like yeah i know that's not
what i do you know
uh
you know uh badminton's my game uh
no i i i don't my self-esteem does not
rest in that area but for some reason at
a very young age i decided to put all my
self-esteem on
making people entertained and so the
problem is then you go out night after
night and that's your job and you're out
there and it works more often than it
doesn't but when it doesn't you feel
like someone
fired an ice pick into your gut and it's
and i think that's what makes me try
that much harder and prepare that much
more uh so
that probably is my biggest
you know fear that involves me you know
that that is is and that's the thing
that i think probably motivates me the
most
and
fire like a boulder a big boulder
crushing me
falling
falling sorry wait i've got a few more
getting stabbed
i was also one of the other girls that
you hugged i didn't let you go
i don't know if you remember you too yes
hi
hi
uh if you could be where did you say
we're meeting i can't remember oh yeah
about the after party i remember you
invited us um what
i can't hear that
and maybe that's a good thing
if you could be the lead singer of any
band matthews e10 yeah is that where the
party is afterwards yeah
they don't seem to agree
you got a lot of other people who are
like it's not matthew's e10
if we could be the lead singer of any
band what man would it be i can't hear
you what's that if you could be the lead
singer of any band what band would it be
uh i love hardcore cycle billy
rockabilly music uh
like really uh cranked up uh crazy like
cowboy hat long sideburns
played triple time uh super fast
so um i don't know i love
uh i love that kind of music i love
huh
yes
yes lady gaga describes what i was just
saying
i would say lady gaga
yeah there you go and how many women
have you been with
[Applause]
i'm
i'm thinking
not that many
no i i could never answer such a
question
my religion uh forbids me
as soon as i figure out what that is all
right
this is a question from our dean of
students what's the fabulous marciano
perez
i love him
that guy's amazing he is amazing
actually he's right there yeah how are
you pal
he's asking why didn't you just ask me
the question from there
why don't you march up and hand a piece
of paper
so strange
you have so much power here
you're just sitting there i hope they
read my paper
i hope you reach my page
he's asking if you can please play a
song with the fabulous mike and grady
[Applause]
what's that i added
that's okay that's fine
um
uh you know i don't have a guitar or
anything so uh oh
what
you know that would be uh you know we'll
see why don't we see how everything goes
i played with them backstage it was a
lot of fun but there's been no rehearsal
and these people expect top tier
entertainment and they'll settle for
nothing left
[Applause]
you named your college after me for 24
hours
you'll get your song when some things
change around here
you'll get a lot of things when that
name changes permanently
oh yeah
yes
okay now it's all just falling apart
it's like the end of titanic when you're
like it's falling apart
what's wrong with you are you okay i'm
really excited to meet you come on up
here
come on come on
just sit here with me
[Applause]
[Applause]
what's wrong with you people
i thought you loved me
that was the greatest prank
[Music]
[Applause]
i can't get near your area
or there's going to be like multiple
come up here
my god
[Applause]
go to ucsd conan what's the worst that
could happen
it's not like a girl's going to smash
your face with the back of your head
how are you
how is it is there a mark of any kind is
it okay good
okay
this is the remarkably kind she said no
it's perfectly white
[Applause]
what's wrong
why are you making me sing
you're so sickly in person
i know i know let's be pals thank you
okay just keep my hand right here
all right now you had to ask me
something see it's not so bad we're all
pals here
well you come back every year on april
20th just for us
[Applause]
no
that's too funny to do i'm sorry
you can appreciate that
now either you are all thumping your
feet or i'm bleeding into my brain now
that's what it feels like don't no no
it's okay i'll recover in time and you
may read in the papers tomorrow that i
went to sleep and didn't get up
that's not yeah it could happen
and i don't want you to feel badly
you look after my children i know you're
wrong no
there are other celebrities i'll be no
i'll be quickly replaced
oh thank you so much you know what i
really do love it here and i everyone
has been so gracious to me that uh i'd
love to come back sometime can it be
every year i don't know about that
you should come back every year well
let's see how the whole college name
thing goes
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
not responsible for my actions
all right well it's nice meeting you and
then
oh no the microphone is yours to keep
yes you can have a signature wow okay
you're so unself-conscious up here what
am i oh oh okay
i didn't know what was happening all
right
i got scared and delighted here we
enough words and go feelings
enough warmth and good feelings we have
another question from the box for you
all right
so who is the most annoying celebrity
you have ever met
a question from
there's too many i don't want to answer
that one that's the one that gets out
there that causes problems
annoying
uh there are
you know what i will say i'll tell you
this and it's not naming names but i
will tell you this
and it's true
i have like a uh
70 2010 rule 70 of the people you meet
in show business are really nice
and then there's 20 that are kind of
okay
and then there's 10
where life is too short
and
uh you just they're just you just
they're they're so probably unhappy
and often those are the people that are
putting out the biggest kind of i'm
really happy and then you meet them and
you see that they're just this
festering hole of hate uh
what's that
you know i don't know him too well so i
can't really say but you guys are more
than welcome to shout out names
now everyone's shouting out names
but no i would say that most people most
people are uh
most people show up they do their job
they try they're perfectly nice and then
there's some that are starting to get
high in their own supply and then there
are some that are just completely
uh batshit crazy and uh
and insane and mean and uh
they're they need they need a beating
how about another question for the
microphone
okay so this is gonna be kind of a weird
uh question so i'm just wondering that's
good if you're the only person to
preface with that
okay other people just go for it so i'm
a little bit nervous but um don't just
don't be nervous well i'm sure you give
this a lot of thought and it's a really
good question everyone's listening and
going you're pretty much
you're pretty much like a badass person
that i've known so i'm just wondering
how do you ask a girl that you like them
and how would you get with them
wait how would you
say the question again how would i ask a
girl if i like a girl how would i
approach her yeah is she here tonight no
well dude i could have hooked you up if
she was here right now
that's how we get it done
do you have a cell phone do you want to
call her
i don't steal
[Applause]
wait let the man speak
let the man speak oh does she know you
yeah she knows me no no i don't mean she
sees you outside her apartment sometimes
no i mean
you got to be honest with me here
because the law is going to get involved
at some point
okay um this is someone you know who you
like
yeah
you just gotta you just gotta be honest
with her you know
now i'm going to promise that
the guy that premised that by saying
that never worked for me
but uh but i believe you should be
honest with her all right and i think if
you really want to make an impression
her phone rings
conan o'brien's on the other end
you don't have to do that now with all
these people watching i understand
that's awkward but if you want to find
me after the show
i'll do it you know okay
or maybe that would make things worse
okay
or maybe she and i would start seeing
each other
which is usually how these calls go
right
and um the last part of the question is
oh it's the last part yeah i'm also
looking for like this
can you cut some of her hair and bring
it to me
you're a monster
i'm sorry
go ahead um i have a resume for my work
so i'm sorry if i become an intern that
takes balls i like it bring it forward
what's this for
let me read this no you're through you
didn't bring a resume um
let's see special skills stalking
i've got my eye on you
is it basil or basil
basil does anyone ever say basil
does she call you basil
all right dude that's what we're gonna
do i've got this what kind of drive are
you looking for
interning
well we'll talk
but let's see you've got you've asked
much of me you don't understand that you
want me to fix up your love life and
your professional career
[Applause]
oh and then this girl's gonna hit you
the head with her head
now get out of here and guess what
school's not named after you after today
all right i got this
yes how can i help you
hi gordon hi how are you
i'm pretty good how about you i'm okay
see basil this is how it's done
[Applause]
so uh
what's going on man
just watching you yeah
[Applause]
it's a real coincidence is that watching
you
now in real life this is usually the
part guys where i start crying
so don't be fooled yes
so they asked about uh your craziest
night in college but what about life in
general your craziest night that you can
remember
your life
there's not one there's been too much
insanity in my career and
it really is like
saying to pavarotti near the end of his
life what was your favorite plate of
pasta like you know
there's just been
there's just been it's there's so
there's been so much absolute craziness
in some of the things that have happened
to me that i obviously i just honestly
cannot access
one of them and say that's the be-all
and the end-all i've you know
i
i
i just had a lot of insane experiences
i've kick-backed with chuck norris and
i taught him a thing or two that's for
sure
uh no i've met most of my heroes i've
met just about everybody i wanted to
meet i've uh
had the opportunity to play guitar with
bruce springsteen and
uh
and cut an album with jack white and you
you know you have all these
you have these all these things happen
and they just you think okay that's it
i'm tapped out i've had more than my and
and
there's just been a lot of crit there's
also been stuff that's gone so horribly
wrong and gotten so weird in the last
couple of years that it's been in a way
transcendent i wouldn't change any of it
you know but everything i went through a
few years ago and then going out on that
tour was one of the best experiences it
was it was two things it was a yin yang
symbol
it was the yin yang symbol of somehow
the worst
uh period of my professional career
being
transmogrified into the best period of
my life you know and i don't understand
to this day so i don't even yeah it's it
was whatever it was it was pure the good
was pure the bad was pure it was honest
it was real and uh and i i've always
thought that i'm gonna probably at some
point just have to stop doing this
wait 10 years and take a nap and then
get up and write it all down because
it's been and i don't think anyone would
believe half of it it's been so weird
but uh
you know it's a lot of you were too
young to know this but
back in 1993 when i'm sure
people
you were born in 1993
that's funny because i was going to say
i had a child
who i lost track of
who i mailed to san diego
yes i see the hair as a giveaway um
father uh
when i um
if you go back a long time and no one
you can't appreciate it but
at the time
there wasn't nearly as much television
there were just a couple of there was
literally it was
four networks at the time
cable wasn't wasn't really around and
there was basically
you know two shows there was johnny
carson
and there was david letterman and david
letterman
uh left announced he was leaving and
there was an opening and
uh the tonight show was taken so he was
like all right i'm going to leave and go
to cbs and there was an opening
and
there was this search to find somebody
to take his place
and if you calculated my odds of getting
that beforehand a computer would have
said they're so infinitesimally small it
could never happen nobody knew who i was
i was not an established performer i was
a writer i didn't i had no
it's insanity and literally 50 things
had to go wrong for me to get that job
and then i was in over my head
for at least a year and struggling and
and having all kinds of problems so
surviving that was miraculous do you
know what i mean and now i meet all
these young people who've grown up
watching me and i try to explain to them
that you know i never really even should
have had that job in the first place
and they say what are you talking about
i
you know i was in diapers watching you
they're talking about two years ago
because they have some kind of problem
but
they're all but you know they say i and
they grew up watching me and so they
don't understand that
that the craziness of me getting that
late night job in the first place was
unprecedented and at the time people
were flipping out and uh it was really
young people that started saying hey i
like this show this guy's really weird
he's got to calm down his hair is a
freak show
i don't know did he make up that name
his voice sort of sounds like a girl's
uh what's going on with this guy and
that took a long time to play out but
they liked the show and it it so just
surviving i think was probably the
biggest weirdest miracle
of my career
i'm glad my pain brought you pleasure
so here's a question from tamara
freeland who's a senior in communication
yay communication i'm teaching the
department right now so i like it all
right
what is one of your most embarrassing
childhood memories you people want to
see me humiliated
they want to know about your fear and
shame i know
my most embarrassing childhood
even realize memories
oh i realize it
uh wow most embarrassing childhood
memories uh man there's so many
i think there's nothing worse in the
world than when someone says hey
everybody look at me
when you say to people hey everybody
look at me
it means that you really have your act
down do you know what i mean like if you
have worked out a trick
shot in basketball or pool
or you have a cool thing you can do and
you stop a whole bunch of people who are
talking and you say hey everybody look
at me it means you know what you're
about to do
i had worked out this funny thing i was
gonna do
and i was in front of all my cousins i
was about nine years old and this is in
a park a place called watch hilbrod
island and it was night time and it was
summer and all my cousins are playing
and i had this funny somersault that i
was gonna do and i stopped everybody and
i said hey everybody look at me
and started to run to do my somersault
and fell
into the largest pile of dog [ __ ] i've
ever seen
and was just my whole chest
like this this dog was sick
and i fell into it and i had made
everybody stop and i said hey everybody
look at me
and ran and fell they all saw it
happened and laughed
then they kept laughing and laughing and
laughing all my cousins and my friends
that hung out and watched show and then
it was time to go home
and
my parents put me in the back of the
station wagon and everyone sat in the
very front
and i just sat back there covered in
excrement
i haven't thought about that till this
night
for that i thank you
thank you
ucsb
perhaps there's a question over here
huh i made it all right how you doing
conan hey dude dude you gotta bring back
the beard
you know i gotta say i get conflicting
things on the beard no no no it's very
it's good
okay but you know what for every guy is
like dude where's the beard there's
someone else who's like hated that beard
so glad it's gone so it's very divisive
the beard i got rid of it eventually
because i was
sick of
the you know beard maintenance and beard
like it's just beard stuff you find
things in your beard
there's certain foods that are offline
chili's gone you can't have chili
anymore no creative custard all pies are
out uh taffy i can't have taffy uh i had
to get i had to lose it for myself i did
it i grew it for myself and i got rid of
it for myself
and you and when you grow up yes that's
right i shaved off my own beer and i'm
proud that i did it
but uh my question is oh i thought that
was a question yeah come on well that
was like a compliment no that was a
compliment i don't know that was like
what out of your face
your face doesn't look right anymore
i liked your face the old way
but anyway thanks for the compliment it
wasn't a compliment but anyway
uh that's all right
i know you're running around your neck
well
it's a lake i got it because i'm awesome
but anyway
oh my god you missed the first part of
the show you weren't here i'm scared
i'm scared for the future of this
country
i'm wearing a lay because i'm awesome
why else would you wear one
okay good point
he knows all right so i know you're a
family man just curious what is your
favorite disney family man what is your
favorite disney movie
my favorite what disney movie oh there
you go i'm sorry acoustics a little bit
of problem and i just wanted to hear you
yell angrily disney movie what is it i
said disney movie does something sound
funny when they're yelled angrily yes
illegally
which one come on
i gotta go
i gotta grow this thing out some more
um man uh favorite disney movie of all
time
uh
animated or live action animated of
course come on oh oh come on come on
come on you ever watch mary poppins oh
god that's got amazing music
spoonfuls make some medicine go down
hello
chimney sweeps i love that stuff
oh i don't know what do i know i'm gonna
uh what's that
yeah nemo
i know you know what i i don't have an
answer you're not an emo guy i don't
have an answer i'm not uh i i watch
disney movies but i'm not one of them i
don't have them like tattooed on my back
or anything right
i'm not putting on your tattoos but i
don't know
i i don't know that looks great
ariel looks beautiful uh
but i don't uh i don't really i don't
have a favorite i gotta say i'm sorry i
can't help you on that one who's the
funniest person you've had on your show
uh there's i wouldn't say there's one
funniest there's a group of people who
are my favorite will ferrell makes me
laugh so
um
i cry and he's like that too
in just life i mean uh
once i was just taking like a
trans uh i was taking a flight from new
york to l.a this is a bunch of years ago
when he was still on snl and we just
happened to be sitting next to each
other we spent the whole flight in
character acting like idiots
and we were like turning away food so
that we could keep whatever i don't
remember the stupid bit we were doing
but we were both doing this
stupid thing and so he's absolutely uh a
joy uh to talk to he really
makes me laugh um so he might be one of
my all-time favorites
people
to uh to talk to i would say
[Applause]
people stay far away from the mic before
they ask
as if they're afraid
here's a serious question for you conan
it's like you're about to sing an
acoustic song
here's one i think
do you like your eggs fried
or do you like them very little
well i'm gonna go with pride
good
a
god
place
but yet so wondrous
i would say fried i like a fried egg
there i took your dirty question and
turned it around
made it very wholesome
is how i like it with wheat toast
cup of coffee with skim milk i might
have some orange juice with that
there you go
[Music]
was there more to that or that was it i
think that was it
that's all
right
a question from alvin portillo a second
year student who's a computer science
major from norwalk california
alvin wants to know have you ever
considered doing an episode dressed as
the flaming sea
uh no
i think that would involve seeing
contour of body if your life was a movie
who would play the different roles uh
well yeah i'd be played by tilda swinton
uh
[Applause]
uh andy richter would play uh be played
by jack black i think
uh my wife
uh would be played by angelina jolie
she may see this tape and so
um
you
[Music]
you would be played
by the guy with the scruffy beard on
flight of the concords
[Applause]
uh that's all i got i don't know the
other people around here that well
um and you could the rest of you can
play yourselves when the movie is made
this event
you'll be paid nothing
and the last question which comes from
the box is from anthony mendoza who is a
first-year student
who is actually from here uh in the
general region from san diego and he
asks
and he made no effort to come here he
just
rolled out of his house and came to
college
that's right interesting and uh anthony
wants to know what is the most illegal
thing you've ever done
the most you know i'm pretty square i
have to say that i'm i'm pretty square
that's a wow that's a tough question
the most illegal thing i've ever seen
what was written here oh you could add
it on your own
[Music]
you can see beforehand i don't know uh
let's see i'm gonna have to think about
that the most illegal thing i've ever
done
i don't know it's probably something
really lame i wish i could make
something up that sounds cool
but
i stole a cessna once and took it flew
it and i have no flying license uh
so but that was everyone's done that uh
i poisoned a guy's food once
he died but we've all done that
uh
i you know it would be something like
being alone in my car driving
cross-country and no one's around and
going like 170 miles an hour
just because i wanted to see what it was
like and then realizing that all i have
to do is hit a tiny snail in the middle
of the road and uh my fort taurus and i
would explode so
that's probably it i hate to say i'm not
i'm not a badass i know you guys see the
image
you're like that guy's you know
kick some ass in his day and he's cut
some people and he's
had his way with the ladies and all of
that's true but
none of it was illegal you know i'm
saying
it was all in combat situations
where the government uh had pretty much
allowed me to do my thing
well thank you so much
and
do they only want one let's just do one
more
let's see if someone has a good question
this guy's wearing a tie
he should put i haven't seen anyone here
wearing a tie i just came from work
who was he a student
no administrators don't count
everyone else is wearing a hawaiian lay
or
[Applause]
oh hi
so i've been a big fan of yours since
you did that christy alley bit with the
i don't remember what that was oh man i
swear to god i've done so i do 35 stupid
things a night and i cannot tell you
such a big part of my life is people
coming up to me i and this is absolutely
true and saying oh man
the time that you tackled
you know don wrinkles and you both fell
in melted cheese
and then you fired that gun in the air
and the walrus died
and i'll say i don't know what you're
talking about that never happened that
never ever ever happened and then they
put in a piece of tape and it shows all
of that happening so that's my life i
don't remember what that was but i'm
sorry to admit that this would be light
okay
maybe you can still answer my question
um
in your honest opinion what would
christy ally do for a klondike bar
i wish i just i thought i was being nice
by saying one more question
i saw your tie i thought this is going
to be good
it's going to be about what can you tell
us about the future
and then it's christie ali in a klondike
bar
i i can't help you out pal i want to end
on a high note here all right i want to
elevate this evening
you know i mean that woman lost a lot of
weight and i think we should get behind
her
wow no one cares okay
positive energy not working with you
guys all right
anyway let's uh
what's that
someone gave me this bracelet today
[Music]
start ucsd
to start wrestling
okay well that made you happy and
annoyed everyone else
so thank you okay
i'm your favorite redhead there aren't
that many
that's sad like when you say you're my
favorite person you're my favorite guy
on television but you're like no you're
my you're my favorite chirp cheekboned
redhead
who was educated on the east coast
uh whoo what
nice
um
let me end on a high note here
what's that
well that's not the way to do it
actually every writer i've hired stood
up at the end of a seminar and screamed
that question to me
unintelligibly and they were immediately
hired
congratulations
that's our process i hope you liked it
um
i think my time is up here but i'm going
to leave you with these words i honestly
besides all the joking and fooling
around uh it was a real honor to be
invited down here there's nothing i like
more in the world than talking to young
people
who are smart and funny
and uh
so
good luck to all of you i'm sure you'll
see me around la and if you do say hi
because i have many i actually am one of
those people that likes to say hi to
people so when you
when you see me in la getting out of my
gold bentley
with the license plate stud
with four d's
uh
wearing my pimp hat
uh
what's that
what part of the leg do you want the
address
we'll talk separately
um but anyway please come up and say hi
to me and uh i like to my favorite part
about this business and about this job
is meeting people and making some kind
of connection and then whether it's five
years from now 10 15 20
you say i molested you or i hit you in
the head with my head
at ucfd
and it's going to mean a lot to me so
thank you very much thanks for coming
out tonight
see you guys later bye
[Applause]